[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host scroll and this video we're
breaking down one of the big reveals in
secret Invasion if you've caught the
finale then you'll know that we finally
see Rowdy getting freed from scroll
captivity and him being one was supposed
to be one of the show's big twists all
the way back in episode 3 we discovered
that he'd been swapped out and this came
with a phone called davara summoning
them to meet upon arriving at the church
he was ordered to kill her husband and
this is when it was hammered home that
Roadie was a scroll in me you know I'm
56 years old damn
I'm sorry revealed to be called rabba
This is actually a scroll from the
comics who ended up becoming a pirate
that was imprisoned along with Black
Bolt rather worked alongside him whereas
here she's clearly a villain that's
desperate to be seen in her own skin now
one of the big questions uh you probably
have right now is when exactly did she
snatch him and how long has Rodi been a
scroll for
why don't you explain this to me like
I'm five throughout this video we're
gonna be breaking it all down and
nailing exactly when it was that he was
switched out there are some people
saying that it's Civil War but we'll
explain why that isn't actually the case
if you enjoy the video please hit the
thumbs up button and also don't forget
to subscribe for breakdowns like this
every day without the way huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
when Roadie was a scroll okay so the
finale has Gaia overpowering gravic and
she blasts a hole through his chest
leaving him dead for good no idea why he
can't heal from this as he also got
stabbed there earlier but will not
coming on the finale even though it's
getting pretty pooped on online 13 on
Rotten Tomatoes God damn either way
after this guy goes into whether humans
are housed and we see several of the
faces who've popped up in the series
this includes the Daltons the dealer
from episode one and Everett Ross
alongside Rowdy Gaia says he's being
held hostage for a long time and the
character needs to be carried out so
that he can get home now this shows that
we have at least one definite moment in
time that the one we were following had
to be human we're already of course
crashed landed during Civil War and in
the aftermath of the airport battle he
ended up being paralyzed the factory
John Walker shows that he at least went
through that and they aren't explaining
the recast from Terence Howard with some
shape-shifting meta joke now I have seen
some people say that it could be because
he's been there for so long that he's
gained muscular atrophy and because of
this he can now no longer walk I know
that's the case because it's gonna set
them back so much and I think personally
the the creative team would just avoid
doing that now going back to the scene
Rowdy's wearing a hospital gown which we
also saw him wearing during Civil War
put into an MRI machine this is the last
time we saw him wearing it and because
of this people think that he was
snatched right after this let's be
honest it would make sense too and him
going through this would give the
opportunity to switch a route but I'm
not a rapper going off the math it would
be a devastatingly long time as well
because civil will actually happen
during 2016. secret invasion is set
during the year 2025 and going off the
UFO hearings this week yeah we we may be
invaded by that point either way this
has left a lot of people thinking he was
grabbed then and because of this fans
have been getting bloody angry it robs
all the character development that
Roadie's gone through and everything
that we saw happening with him in
endgame however I think there's two
clues that show this isn't the case and
that Roadie was grabbed by the Scrolls
long after end game and the biggest
indicator of this comes down to his leg
braces which once more give him the
ability to walk these were seen during
Avengers Infinity war and he also had
them on an end game as well this
happened not only at the start of the
movie but also at the end when he was at
the funeral during the point where
Avengers hq's attacked we also have him
rolling at his suit and he has to crawl
across the floor this is when he gets
into his Mark II armor but I doubt
rather would just lay there and keep up
appearances because everything's going
to hell the cover to me at this point
would have broke so looking at this yeah
I think it's still him during the third
act we also see Roadies bleeding as well
and as we know scroll blood always shows
as purple even when RAV has killed the
wall behind the lines with purple blood
which is a pretty important factor when
it comes to their species so therefore
he couldn't have been a scroll during
this unless they retroactively go back
and I'm like oh mate look look over
there while we change the VFX so yeah I
think at least during end game that he
would have been normal but it's at this
point that things likely changed now
another reason that I don't think Rowdy
was a scroll before this is because of
what we know when it comes to the
Harvest in the series we learned it was
at the funeral Fury had Scrolls moving
around and collecting DNA so it could
formulate the formula this was made up
of both villain and hero and going off
the list of names it had to be then
people like Gamora romantis have only
been Earth during this period so this
indicates that this is the point in
which most of them were grabbed at this
time graphic was team Fury so it also
doesn't make sense that they would have
grabbed Rowdy before it this is when he
started it out what his master was up to
but any time before that he wasn't
swapping humans out so it would have
been weird for rather to grab Rowdy
before this because as far as I knew
Fury was still trying to get them home
he'd of course been snapped for five
years at this point and I really doubt
that they would have been holding that
against him what really seem to anger
the Scrolls was after this point when he
went up to cyber and refused to come
down this was the switch that sent them
off in their Vendetta so them grabbing
Rowdy before this just doesn't really
make sense so I think with all the
things here that Roddy was still a human
during end game and if he's not made
we're gonna kick off I think
stripping him of all the character
development and saying goodbye to Tony
would just anger fans at the point they
would kick off with buggy directly
talking about stealing his hat at one of
those fancy premieres and running about
with it and being like I've got your
heart now from this point onwards we get
a clue that he was changed after this
point do you know how he appears in
Falcon and the Winter Soldier the braces
he had are now completely missing and
this is something I carried across the
secret Invasion too I think the brace
elements used to demonstrate when he was
a scroll and we should mainly go off
them to nail a timeline down now
technically also this doesn't negate
what Gaia says and when we look at the
Timeline it could still be a long time
as we mentioned before Seeker invasions
set during 2025 and Avengers end games
actually set during 2023 Balkan and the
Winter Soldier happens just weeks after
this putting it in the summer of the
same year so Rory being captive for two
years is still a long time and you think
about that in terms of your own life
imagine what you were doing two years
ago and you can kind of see why it's so
devastating for him to be locked up this
long I remember once yeah when I was a
kid I went on holiday for two weeks and
I came back and the entire local shop
had changed it was mental mate I still
haven't forgot it but this shows how big
of a time Jump that two years could be
so judging on all that evidence I think
it paints out a clear picture and Rody
might have been grabbed right after the
funeral he probably wasn't thinking
straight due to his friend dying and
this would also likely mean his senses
weren't as strong I think that the
Scrolls grabbed him roughly after this
point possibly during a visit where he
went out to a hospital armor Wars is
likely going to clear this whole thing
up and I imagine that we'll get a scene
showing when it happened now if they say
it was before end game you know the
whole blood thing mate and I hope you're
right in the comments on the trailer you
bloody son of a I'm coming
to get your hat obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on when you think it
went down though but I think going off
the evidence this is the most likely
time please drop a like on the video and
if you want to support the channel as a
member of this spoiler Society then
please click the join button you'll get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
you also have our merch store over at
shopzerodation.com which sells lots of
nerdy inspired t-shirts hats and more
we're just about to close out on the
secret Invasion slash Pulp Fiction
inspired t-shirt so if you want to head
over then help us out then the links in
the description now if you want
something else to watch we've got a
bright end of the finale on screen right
now going over all the Easter eggs that
pop up in the episode hopefully I see
you over there but if I don't I won't
hold it against you and yeah thank you
for sitting through this support
I'll see you next time mate you take
care of yourself peace